>> I think it's a difficult question to answer
yes or no.
I think that um, the question is more about
-- it's not necessarily
about whether a specific country or specific
solution will be found to
pull the world out of it's global economic
crisis.
I think the question is more about identifying
an area or a theme.
We're involved a lot in renewable energy and
energy efficiency projects
in China.
And I think that there is an awful a lot of
opportunity for growth in
the commercial components of transfer of technology
and I think that if
we can inspire technology transfer and then
have the correlation -- the
correlative effects much growth involved in
the overseas countries
where the energy or the technologies is actually
being developed, as
well as the growth of the technology production
in China, and I think
that if we can grow that, then it will help
to pull the world out of
it's economic crisis.
So I think there's been lots of discussion
about a green revolution and
a green revolution is not just about saving
the environment, it's also
about economic opportunity.
And I hope, I very much hope, that the world
begins to see that and
people and particularly countries and commercial
industry begins to
take advantage of it.